but what was the uh bonnaroo news this
week that i missed because i'd be honest
with you i've not paid attention to
anything yeah go ahead taco
they've made some improvements on the
farm
uh number one stormwater management
planning and drainage improvements
i know you guys love drainage
i always like to see that way up high on
the poster well yeah first billing yeah
uh but if if they don't have the sewage
improvements uh
you know it yeah these are these are all
filed under
uh
only us would be talking about it but
we're glad they did all of them can i
tell you uh
a ban that we've had on this program
before came to town and they performed
at a
venue in town that will stay nameless
and
i heard that
it got so uncomfortable it's a packed
house
but unfortunately
because it was the first show back into
real life
something had happened with the sewage
lines
and when
everybody would flush the water was
going the opposite direction
so when you walked into the bathroom you
were having to walk around
rivers of sewage
so the whole venue smelled like raw
sewage
i don't care who's on stage that's dad
bad night i don't care who is it yeah
paul nice to see you mr mccartney uh
have a good night
i'm out
yeah gotta go
we've all been on the farm when things
weren't going well
i try not to talk about it like i said i
worked at a funeral home i don't talk
about that i don't talk about things
i've seen in porta potties on the farm
yeah but you really did get a lot of
girlfriends from that funeral home
it's a chick magnet yes it is
[Music]
what's the second line on that uh
improvement poster
uh let's see you got relocation of
parking and camping areas to better
prepare for weather events
now this sounds kind of known well you
know that just sounds like fancy words
for moving brad
and i don't run
i don't like it
this doesn't sound good to me right now
we can read between the lines on that
yeah
this is just fancy words to say
we don't like where you're camping brad
so we're moving you somewhere else
yeah
yeah we're gonna that's that's an issue
for later
so at what point so explain to me the
parts that they would need to move you
from
and move you to
so that it would
be weather flexible
i don't know but they put a little
picture of a bus on here so i like it
[Laughter]
once again thumbs up for me poster
management yeah that's all you need yeah
it gives a thumbs up from me
thank a lot
the only thing i can think of is
remember the big storm from what four or
five years ago as they just cleared out
center road
yeah and where
you went there
and they built a bridge kind of on your
own yeah built the bridge now i
understand there's low levels of the
farm and and you know the the storm that
rolled through ida last year that killed
the festival i understand that
there's a reason the grounds were
that's probably
probably hit it you probably nailed it
right there i know that but where are
they moving them to it's i mean they
don't have endless space
yeah i don't know probably higher i
don't know i i would assume they paid
attention to
higher ground and that sort of thing
were you just about to say they moved to
hell i was
but i let it go
it probably did move some hills but not
the hill you're you're
brad always wins in the end brad always
wins in the up this one
thank you go ahead
they've paved roads there's additions of
pave roads across the farm
paving roads
would you be okay if they paved
the main roads inside cenaru that's what
i think they did no and at first i
thought no i don't like that um
i don't think unless you remember that
big puddle that forms there
leaving vip going into cenaru
be cool if that was not there anymore
i know i know that but
i just have roads across festival
grounds it doesn't specifically say
center room now i could see if they
paved the main drags around camp right
and but i just don't know if i would be
okay with them paving roads inside
cinero why
something would feel
almost
you'd miss the dust and the puddles you
know it's not just the dust or the
puddles it just feels
i don't less connected to the earth
maybe i i had the same thought over the
weekend but then i kept thinking about
those puddles that you got to walk you
know when you go through those wooden
gates
stepping over and around
there's no fun in that i understand i
don't know why i don't haven't
i haven't really put a finger on why
this would bother me but it would make
me feel a little uh a little bougie a
little like uh i feel like i'm at a city
festival all of a sudden i think the
point of being a bonnaroo is that you
get these rough around the edges things
i don't i don't know if i'd love a uh
i'm okay with the flushing toilet okay
let me make that clear i'm okay you're
not you're around the edges guy i know
that but this makes me feel like i am
oh this is it
okay they got gravel roads and
everything
yeah
maybe we need to do a little recon and
go down to manchester and see exactly
what they think that's exactly what we
need do you think they've already done
them or they're just saying that they're
going to do them
uh makes it sound like it's been done
why are you going to talk them out of it
wait a second we have kyle lives in
manchester
oh yeah we can get him over there why
don't we just get kyle drive over there
and see if you can uh see any paved
roads
yeah take video
yeah
i don't know man the last place they
need paved roads is incenteroo they
already drive too many carts through
there to begin with um the the the
bumpiness and that actually slows them
down they need to take the service roads
behind because the carts drive me nuts
driving through there that was sort of
part of the plan that was announced two
years ago when it didn't happen that
they had come up with ways to move the
carts around the perimeter man i hope so
i do too that's the most because man i
tell you that the best part of
lollapalooza is how they have organized
sort of their transportation in and
around that festival uh the carts
driving through
bonnaroo don't make any sense and they
just get in the way yeah coming up on
you all the time yeah and also and also
paving roads would mean that they're you
know planning to continue
driving through cenaru when it's much
more important to get paved roads out
around uh the premises don't you think
yeah maybe yeah it's part of the uh
wastewater management
rainwater and all that
all right what else we got on the poster
new wayfinding system to better help you
navigate the farm day and night
okay that's just a sign that's just a
sign
yeah that's it
this way
and then finally even faster entry to
campgrounds due to tow booth and parking
efficiencies yeah this look i just made
it better there
oh there it is
i did it
now i can find my way man i just spent a
lot of money on that new sign
send an email
but
yeah there's
it's a sign right we're talking about a
sign we're talking about uh
[Music]
okay
what else could it be i mean yeah
probably
you know i don't know that's for those
people who have to camp way way way out
do they still own
scorcho
no let's go
they rented it then they didn't own it
no they didn't own it okay because if
they owned it it would be kind of cool
to take the squatch
and drive it around with like
announcements on
the big screen and you get to see what's
going on and you know do karaoke into it
you know you could put it to use it work
all right now that would be a pretty
good you know
sign you know that would be a pretty
good investment they bought the scorch
and they they've turned it into
you know its own character no i'll tell
you that would be a great rehab
to it's its reputation everybody hates
the scorch el scorcho is back and all of
a sudden it's its own character driving
around making everybody happy
i agree maybe you could wear a scorcho
costume
a mini scorch midi scorch
hey
mardi gras is 345 days away
you gotta have it you gotta start
working on that interesting yeah can i
make it now
yeah so that's it those are the big ones
yes they're gonna let people in on
tuesday
uh and the sooner you get there the
closer you are camped to center room
first is pretty big yeah
yeah that would that i always wondered
about that people who
you know bust their ass to get there
early and then get the worst parking
that sounds like that sounds like the
lead that sounds like the biggest piece
of information here that the sooner you
get there
the closer you get to be yep because
weren't we saying a couple years ago
that you know you could get there on a
tuesday but you're still you know yeah
first yeah they start from back move you
know towards the middle well that's not
new they've been announcing this for two
years yeah there's just been no bonnaroo
to show for it actually do it
so that's it
they should just keep announcing stuff
just
who cares
you know if we 50 50 if this map happens
certain announcements stuff
hey the rolling stones are headlining
yeah yeah all right look good uh that's
uh that's all right i mean i think a lot
of that's uh
some good pr work finally
but i don't know if uh much of that is
is meat it feels like the meatier part
is is you get to camp as close to center
as you can the easier or sooner you get
there yeah yeah i think russ and i were
talking before you got on any any of
these improvements are the kind of
things that you know don't normally make
the headlines but
as we've all said over the years the
little things they add up
that's right flushable toilets that's
right that's right and and the grounds
have uh definitely gotten better and
they look so much better and i will to
your point barry i think that the reason
why we don't hear about them they
announce them plenty but we don't hear
about them because
there's other stuff about it that we're
talking about you know there's so many
other things that were but because we're
in this
you know a barren desert of information
about you know what bonnaroo is going to
be we haven't done it in how long
now it feels like every teeny tiny scrap
of information feels like a feast any
news is news yeah for sure